I've autographed sign grant heals my 95  so we can get for them  you got Grant Hill his signature on Oh  what's a good spacing or David that's a  face that's it that's it  I got him now black now gray healed now  brand-new brand-new never put my foot  son  how about to power what you want for I  thought they'd do the can Sam I don't  wanna give cheating he's 7 for the  business I bet we could just get him  busted minor down mmm I got some the  brown sauce on my foots tuba phone now  mmm not really no no I got ahold of bro  I got LeBron hat side Jersey twits  what you want phone you got emails I get  I'm all right  are we doing all right bring them  through we'll take a look not if I agree  you got you got you got you realizing  those you ain't see them haven't seen  them in a minute yeah now I'll bring my  family to check them out let you fill on  yeah let me talk some business